(melodic guitar music)
( moves to lively rock music)
(rock music slows)
[The King] And we have
that beheading on Saturday.
- Ah, yes and this Sunday,
we have our annual potluck
with the king and queen of Toluca.
How delightful!
- [King] Ummm.
- Oh, and Prince Theodore shall be there.
You know he is currently
unattached to a princess.
- Yeah, because he’s gay.
- More tea my dear?
- Ugh, whatever!
- Now Brittania, we’re
getting closer and closer
to our agreed upon date.
- Father, I know, you
post scrolls in my bedroom
like every day.
(strum of a harp)
(groans) Dad.
- You remember our agreement?
If you can’t find a suitable
prince by the end of the year,
I’ll choose one for you.
- [Princess] You'll choose one for me.
- I know.
[King} That's right.
- But also, you are
free to make any choice
that your little heart desires.
- (groans) Why are you the worst?
Why are you so wicked?
(door slams)
- You’re not wicked my dear.
- Thank you.
(door slams]
(door slams)
(slow acoustic music)
- [Handmaiden] Good eve, Princess.
- Oh, hey Mina.
- Did you get a new spinning wheel?
- Yeah.
It’s like my third one,
I don’t really know how they work though.
- What’s wrong?
Is your privilege as a
rich, white, noble woman
no longer pleasing to you?
- No, it’s not that.
Just my dad and my wicked stepmother,
they don’t listen to me,
I’m not interested in Princes.
- We should go to the
Flaccid Crossbow tonight.
- I don’t know.
- All of the fair maidens will be there.
- Ok.
I do have a pretty gay dress
I’ve been wanting to wear.
- Feast your eyes on these prospects.
- My eyes aren’t hungry.
- Oh, look at that brooding beauty.
The town poet,
she practically speaks in couplets.
A romantic, who would thrust
courtly love upon thy bosom.
♫ For I will thrust
courtly love on thy bosom,
♫ bosom ♫
- For whom if you are wrong,
she will document the
pain you have caused her
in the hopes of making
you a social pariah.
- But I will slash the
seats of thy royal carriage.
(dramatic music)
Bethesda.
- How about Hildebrand?
Her herbal remedy cured
my fever last week.
- Oh, that’s endearing.
Any side effects?
- No
Well sometimes when I sneeze,
I do climax.
- [Princess] That sounds awful.
- Nay, Now all it takes
is a pinch of pepper,
and I am off to the races.
(sneeze)
(moans)
- Oh, god.
- I, I can see how that might get awkward.
- Yeah.
- What about Jesterca?
- Hey, what’s with the
feudal system, right?
I mean, if I wanted to give up my goods
to a fat white guy, I’d
just go back to whoring it.
- No, mmhmm.
- Kisses will only get you so far.
- She’s not bad.
- I can’t, the bells, the props,
the burlap sack,
ventriloquist dummy, I, no.
- Ok.
How about?
( sexy drum beat)
- Who, who welded together oak and oar?
(spits)
Oak and oar.
Really?
- Observant.
Strong.
For she could build you a
castle with her bare hands.
(hammer bangs)
She makes me question my own desires.
Anyone would be lucky to
make her acquaintance.
- Seems like someone already has their eye
on that blacksmith.
- What?
Oh. (laughs nervously)
Moving on.
You’ll most certainly enjoy the company of
Lady Meredith,
the most caring of all the maidens,
and what a nurturing soul,
and very familiar with female anatomy.
- But a known virgin.
She spends all day attending to vaginas,
but doesn’t actually touch them.
- You are a very hard to please princess.
- I’m sorry, but the
last girl that I dated
only talked to animals,
I’m mean I'm a little afraid to
jump back into the dating moat.
- Ok, the last eligible maiden is
that peasant over there.
- I’m not into waking up early,
or her dirty finger nails.
(soft harp music)
Who is she?
I don’t recognize her.
(explosion)
[Blacksmith] I can fix that.
I just need a hammer, a
nail, a hammer and a nail.
I need a blowtorch, and a...
- Her slipper.
- Don’t touch it,
it could be ridden with disease.
(sneeze) (moan)
[Voiceover] And so Princess Brittania
vowed to find the peasant girl,
for true love had never
appeared so clearly,
or worn such nice shoes.
X-O-X-O.
- No, we’re not doing that.
[Voiceover] Oh, bloody hell.